I don't know how I got through school I
never thought I would get through grade
school high school I'm terrified of
everything I just wanted to get through
it a lot of people enjoy things they
have fun I think that's carried with me
do you are you someone who really could
enjoy things or do you are you doom and
gloom it doesn't seem like you are that
kind of guy seems like you could just
you're like hey I'm gonna have fun I'm
gonna go on set every day I just don't
want to get through it
well
yeah I'm I can just have fun and I can
really apply myself it also took me
28 years to figure out what that thing
was going to be
right like it took me 28 years why do
you say that why because that's when I
settled on acting
and it makes me feel being on set
working on set makes me feel a way that
nothing else does professionally
that is what were you doing before 28 I
was acting a little bit but you know I
was getting committed to it you really
didn't know this is what you're going to
do no I no I I I committed to the idea
that I wanted to be famous
I'm glad you admit that because there's
so many actors who come on here and I go
for me I gotta admit when I was a kid I
thought I want to be in the mood you
know a certain age I want to be in the
movies I want to be famous I want to
make money I want yeah that that's
exciting
I want to be an actor no that was I mean
I of course I did I want to get better I
did theater and I did classes and I got
better and better but deep down I really
did want to be famous 100 and it wasn't
until I abandoned that idea and just
decided look if that happens that's
great but I actually just I really enjoy
acting yeah like and you know one of the
reasons that I enjoy it is because I
enjoy watching television I enjoy
watching movies I enjoy thinking about
performances in the same way that I
enjoy talking about baseball and arguing
stats and watching football except I I'm
not good enough to be a pro basketball
player I'm not good enough to be a pro
baseball player I'm good enough to be a
professional actor like I get a chance
to do it so when I abandoned that and
just thought to myself I'm gonna I'm
gonna do this because it makes me happy
naturally
then a lot of the
superficial and materialistic things
that come with acting then come along
with it right and now I can say I'm
doing it for the love of it but
concurrently I can say that because I'm
very well compensated when I do it right
do you pinch yourself still are you able
to be grateful are you able to sit there
and take a smile and say look what I've
accomplished good for you did you ever
think you're gonna make it this far just
being good to yourself or do you not
really think about those things I don't
really think about those things
I will say that
that
getting done with arrow and moving away
from it and hopping off that
that the proverbial hamster wheel there
gave me a little bit more perspective
and I certainly I am I am very grateful
I love nothing more than I love nothing
more than than being on a on a film set
and
um you know being someone that comes in
comes prepared comes with a good
attitude but also brings a tries to
bring a professionalism that is
appreciated by the crew and the cast as
well you want to be respected and and
appreciated I want to be respected and I
want to be appreciated and I also want
to try to get people home to their
families at a reasonable hour that's a
good thing it is right and I'm not that
doesn't mean cutting corners
but you know there's there's a lot of
things that actors do not so much actors
that I work with on sets that I'm on
because I don't
because I for the majority of the time
over the past 10 years I'm the de facto
leads so you can't if if I'm behaving
one way you have to follow suit because
otherwise it otherwise it sticks out
right but
um you know a lot of things that actors
do on set and they're they're process
can um drive you crazy well it's
indulgent let's be honest it's a little
masturbatory you should be able to just
jump into it let's just do this let's
[ __ ] go there's two guys guys there's
always there's always take two that's
how I like come on that's what I like I
don't like to rehearse too much let's
get after it let's go let's go let's
shoot the rehearsal shoot the rehearsal
shoot the rehearsal yeah let's go good
things come out good things come out